foreign
send that everywhere
so what the eitone here is revealing is
something that is visible in the Vulcan
but
only to a more subtle eye okay
so what's happening is
you are pulling the handle down
pulling the handle down and it kind of
looks the same kind of
kind of
okay
but if you remember
the top part
its motion originates from another
boom Coq projection home
now if you watch the tip
when the handle is going down
you see I pull the handle down
um the geometry between the cutting
portion and the grip doesn't really
change
but when I project up you see the tips
already jumping up
and what happens is when you get to the
end
the tip
is going to hit
home
first just slightly
not hand first then
tip
on first then tip
the tip tip
[Music]
tip hit pull and then the settling the
the cheese suddenly hop into the power
okay
are you doing your move
back
here's your ground
right that foot hitting well let me see
how the tip wants to go already
that tip goes
and the cut is out
not here
cut out boom
what my hands are doing are just riding
the sword
at the end they do another Pokemon
projection so that the tip doesn't drop
they do on top
if they're not pulling the sword they're
not gripping the sword they're not
driving the sword
so out oh
you see that see how that's pretty if I
were to let go if we go flying that way
if you're over here and you let go it's
gonna go this way
okay
again I I want to use Yuri item
they're made for whistling
they're not like a shinkan
okay
so if you paid attention even though
it's pulling hurt
s down
should be a wrong cut
it's still gonna
still gonna whistle from them
do you think
they're made to whistle okay
my my weapon's not made to it my weapons
made to cut okay it's different
so
as I'm moving
and I do my
um
thank you
okay no top
it's very important
that you understand
if you just
cut someone in half
there's there's a psychological process
what happens is that you'll have uh
focal point isolation and your eyes
you'll have auditory exclusion
you'll lose your awareness okay your
Noto is your opportunity to get all that
okay so you don't want to draw fast
it's it's a kind of uh exiting
meditation so as an exiting meditation
from violence human be human violence so
as you come around it's very slow
you get your breath back okay get your
breath back very slow very slow
releasing all the tension it's gonna
you're gonna have tension in them
and feel for the ground
feel for the ground
okay and and you'll have to to use it to
do that you don't have to release the
lower leg tension okay so I want you to
understand
it that way I don't want you to
just like I tell the deputies don't
holster real fast there's no there's no
point where you have to holster real
there's no point where you have to Noto
real fast if you had to do something
quickly you probably shouldn't put your
sword away okay
so out
here relax start releasing tension
release tension release tension nice and
slow and methodical
release tension jaw
wind chakra okay feel the Earth
got it okay try it again
watch my hand first of all because we're
going to work with this later so we're
going to do Joe Don okay
Community build up here
the Joe Don never never
passes through itself like that you
always have to pass through the get on
face
and the true dawn face
and then that's what comes up to the Joe
Don phase
so this this movement right
try to try to remember that
so whoa
pop
okay
then
here we go
here's our cut where we pull our
tsuka down I think
[Music]
you're working against his Mass
so
okay I don't I don't I can because I
have Superior leverage uh with my Lads
and my body and everything like that
uh and he's got some compromised posture
but it's still a mechanical game
I think with my bad thumbs
and his Superior strength I might not be
able to pull him down okay I won't do it
fast but you can resist yeah not it's
not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
okay
you're hot
is gonna keep the same thing so I'm
gonna cast it out do you see that little
difference there
a little different so we're here body
Boom the ground is there the ground
projection into hand and then
you want to cast him out so that he
keeps going in the kazushi pattern
there's no kazushi pattern here that's
just forcing them down so back where I
was so there's a little puff and then
that keeps going
why does that work
turn around
because he has his leg strength here and
he's gonna resist that energy is what I
keep projecting incrementally into that
kazushi pattern
just like of ethio uran
it's not that I shovel down here
as he keeps resisting and I keep taking
his resistance
projecting It Forward each time so I'm
not using spring okay
so as I'm doing the technique
it might look like I pulled down but
when you compare it it's I'm clearly not
falling down okay I'm more projecting
out
hello so you're here you you take it to
where his resistance is and then that
resistance boom you keep rejecting it
is at the speed of life
so it looks fluid
and you stay up with it
so in other words you can't do one
projection
because you'll lose it
but I'm not pulling down on it this is
my hand stays up with his falling hat
I'm not falling down on his hand
foreign
[Music]
okay let's try cast your cut out
okay so this this movement alone takes
in boxer
that makes him go backwards
it's not it's not this one okay so
you're you're in his body making his
body go down
and I just tell you that so you can
psychologically
give up some of this because if you grab
the forearm you're not going to have
leverage here don't hurt me just slowly
pull your elbow down if you see I can't
hold that
so I'm here
they say not here this chair here
everything is working fine okay now when
I get here
uh he's gonna he's gonna resist
you see okay people resist
I don't want you to picture that this is
an external and I send it out you see my
Center comes up what's happening is as
he as he resists
I protect that energy back into the
ground
and project it out that's that's what I
was trying to say is that in this
technique
you see he's trying to stand up okay but
I keep taking it Forward I don't try to
shove that down
as he tries to stand up I project it
forward and just incrementally
into the uh Circle that you you all know
but it doesn't look like this you see
how I came up and tried to get over the
top
and it's not one thing where I shove
them down and he gets Slinky as as he's
trying to get up I just keep going this
way body acts in unison
same thing here
whoa there it is right there that little
thing and
if he gets another foot on the ground I
keep projecting it into this spiral
oh there it is
so a couple things to note is I'm not
going to do it
externally do you see that
not going to do it externally Center
came up
but
I also aren't going to pull down so that
my I don't have to ID me at all because
I don't have to stay up with him I am
projecting him out
just like if your dog
okay if I he tries to stand up
right I'm not gonna stay still he stands
up boom if I did not move
I would lose him
I have to keep moving he tries to stand
up boom my movement is
hand in the projecting space
okay so the same thing here on shihonage
oh
I have to stay up to keep my hand in the
projecting space okay
from where I can project